Are you okay i'm fine. Ah ha. Where is he
where's your dad hey don't sweat it sis it's
not like your dead husband can die twice
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
Wandavision quicksilver video a lot of people
wondering what was going on with him towards the
end of episode six so i'll explain there was a
couple interviews that the cast did explaining
evan peters participation on the show so we'll
break it all down it also kind of helps explain
what's going on what scarlet witch is doing inside
the hex and what's really going on versus what the
show wants you to think is going on because it's
being very misleading on purpose if you're new to
the channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
we have falcon and winter soldier episodes
coming up after this i'll be doing videos for
all the big marvel stuff this year if we're doing
a new giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and post
all your Wandavision theories on the video careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened
on Wandavision so far through the events of
episode 6 if you haven't seen the episodes yet but
during episode 6 there are several conversations
that scarlet witch has with quicksilver because
she gets very confused with why he looks the way
he does why does he look like evan peters and not
like her brother aaron taylor johnson quicksilver
a lot of their conversations and a lot of the
easter eggs explain what's going on even though
the show itself is meant to be very misleading
purposefully the writers the show runner talked
about how they wanted it to be a giant mind screw
of an episode like they wanted to do a quicksilver
episode but they wanted to do it in the craziest
possible way and screw with the audience's minds
as much as possible mission accomplished it was
a great episode for a number of different reasons
but then kat dennings did an interview after the
episode came out talking about how they actually
filmed evan peters when he came to set to film
all the quicksilver cameo scenes and it made it
sound like it was a very one-off kind of thing
so i'll explain what she said about it what that
means in some of the other lines of dialogue that
sort of support what she was saying about it what
kat dennings was saying about evan peter's role
on the show there's been so many theories about
what's going on with his character is he really
meant to be the mcu version of quicksilver now
is he from the multiverse how do you explain him
showing up and looking like evan peters so the
most important thing starts with his cat dennings
interview she said that in order to prevent evan
peters being on the show from leaking out from
him getting captured on drone shots they actually
filmed him with these special covers when he was
getting in and out of cars but the way she talks
about him coming to set makes it sound like it was
just for this special halloween 90s 2000s episode
like all these crazy extra level measures of
secrecy that they had for him being on set didn't
expand across the entire filming of the show like
he wasn't in a bunch of episodes which makes it
sound like when we pick up with the events of next
week's episode with episode 7 she'll have already
changed everything to the 2010s and will be in
like the modern family parody episode the way
he ended episode 6-2 they had this really long
heart-to-heart conversation where she tries to
explain what she thinks is going on inside the hex
even though she herself doesn't totally understand
it when vision gets into trouble trying to leave
the hex and search to die billy comes rushing
to try and get her to help out he starts sassing
her it's not like your dead husband can die twice
then she blasts him seemingly killing him although
we don't know if he's dead she just blasts him
into all the gravestones making it seem like he's
dead like they could have done anything in this
scene here they specifically chose to have him
blasted into the gravestones which i think is just
a metaphor for him being dead there are a couple
easter eggs and the names on the gravestones too
that i'll talk about in a second but they're not
quite relevant to the quicksilver stuff they're
just like extra meta easter eggs that point to
other different things and like i said when we
pick up with episode 7 the show probably won't
explain where he went or what happened scarlet
witch will probably have another scene like after
episode 3 when vision came back into the house
asking what had happened to monica rambeau where
did she go where did geraldine go and she's like
oh honey she had to leave in a hurry when really
she got rid of her on purpose and she was just
lying to vision about it she'll probably just lie
to billy and tommy if they ask hey what happened
to uncle pietro where did he go oh honey he had to
leave but it feels like the kat dennings interview
and a lot of the other dialogue that evan peters
has during the episode point to him just being a
one-off special cameo like he's not completely
replacing aaron taylor johnson quicksilver in
the mcu even though they kept referring to him as
being recast as pietro they did make a funko for
him though so you will be able to buy a funko of
him looking like this in the halloween costume but
it's a ph row funko not a quicksilver funko during
the episode the first conversation that she has
with him about the difference in the memories like
i don't remember things being that way something
is weird here what's going on when he's talking
about the cutaway gag talking about their history
trick-or-treating and getting typhus he says you
probably suppressed a lot of the trauma then in
the next conversations that they have she's like
you do look different why do you look different
and he says you tell me if i had found shangri-la
i wouldn't want to be reminded of the past either
implying that subconsciously when she created
this version of quicksilver she changed his
appearance so that while she's having this fun
halloween episode that she created for herself
she wouldn't be reminded of the real trauma of her
brother aaron taylor johnson quicksilver dying so
tragically during avengers age of ultron like
when she looks at him later in the episode and
you see him riddled with all those bullets looking
all dead kind of like what happened with vision
back during episode three or four i believe that's
her just remembering the reality of the situation
oh he's dead and i'm just making him look like
he's still alive so what they're implying with
this scene though is that she changed him to
be the funny sitcom version of the character
that looked and acted more like this so that
she would have a quote unquote brother episode
brother coming to visit episode without triggering
her trauma and when he says you tell me asking her
to answer her own question why he looks different
he's basically saying that she was responsible for
everything that you're looking at here the super
twisty meta walking talking x-men mcu-looking
crossover easter egg remember the writers said
that they wanted to do the most mind screw twisty
version of this that they could then later in the
episode when they're sitting down and she's sort
of answering all the questions that he's asking
like what's really going on where did she get all
the kids from where you've been hiding all these
kids he says no need to traumatize beyond the
occasional holiday cameo episode which i think is
the strongest evidence for this evan peters twist
being a one-off thing because he is the big cameo
during the holiday episode the halloween episode
and for those of you wondering about the mom the
mom tattoo on evan peter's arm that's actually a
real tattoo that he's had for many years now so
that's not something intended to be an easter
egg for doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
it's just a coincidence that it also says mom and
the reason why he's remembering all these things
differently like while she says wait a minute i
don't remember things happening that way why are
you saying they happen that way and he's talking
about her repressing trauma we already know that
she can alter people's memories like he says give
people nightmares that's a reference to avengers
age of ultron when she gave them all the visions
but it sounds like it was her subconsciously
changing him so that he would be different
and give more happy sounding quirky memories
as opposed to the reality of her upbringing
in sokovia which was probably much much more
traumatic there were a couple times where they
mentioned nightmare during the episode so i think
people are expecting some bigger cosmic explainer
for what's going on here when he says this is a
pretty big leap from giving people nightmares and
shooting red wiggly woos out of your hands he's
talking about her creating the hex in all its
complexity and then asks how did you even do all
this i'm not some stranger i'm not your husband
you can talk to me a lot of people were asking
why he didn't say i'm your brother like he didn't
reference himself as her brother i think that's
more of a wink to the fact that he knows that he's
not exactly a version of her brother he's like
an amalgam version of her brother's memories and
emotions remixed with what she wants him to be a
very pg version of what her memories actually are
like the trauma of her actual upbringing and when
she answers how she created the hex she genuinely
answers i don't know how i did it i only remember
feeling completely alone empty just endless
nothingness because vision was dead her parents
are dead her brother was dead like when she
blasts him here into the gravestones at the end
of the episode like okay i've had enough out of
you kind of implying that she's done with the
fun moment that they're having here and she's
going to dismiss him and then change everything
to the 2010s you notice there are a couple easter
eggs on the names of the gravestones so dr rivas
isn't an actual name but if you read it backwards
it sounds more like survivor like she has survivor
guilt because she's the only one she's alone
because everybody she knows and cared about is
dead and the funny thing about samplemen though
the samwoman name is actually the name of one of
the producers on one of the fantastic four movies
i don't think it's meant to be a direct fantastic
fall reference sometimes when they need a lot of
different names to appear on screen they'll use
the names of crew members or friends and family
members of the crew members that worked on the
production staff so even though it seems like a
big fantastic four easter egg and there are other
fantastic four easter eggs in the series because
obviously we're going to get a new fantastic
four that'll be connected to sword in some way
i don't necessarily think in this moment it's
meant to be a direct setup for the new marvel
version of fantastic four also people addressing
the nightmare stuff that people are asking about
there's a lot of easter eggs in the episode in
the background including the commercial that
are actually references to what's happening with
vision during the episode so in the commercial you
have a boy on a deserted island that's getting
ready to die if he doesn't get some sort of
sustenance or some food the shark comes along to
give him the yo magic yogurt which is basically
a parody for yo plate yogurt and even though he
does get it they do the joke about him not being
able to open it because the tab is too hard to
open and he winds up dying that's a metaphor for
vision surviving inside the hex sustaining himself
on scarlet witch's magic the magic of the hex in
the metaphor of the commercial the deserted island
represents the hex and the little boy is vision
later in the episode sort of backing up this claim
when billy realizes what's happened to vision when
he leaves the hex if you look at the old black
and white horror movie that's playing on the
projector above them while this is all happening
the movie is the creature walks among us from 1956
and in that movie the creature inadvertently kills
itself after escaping its cage and trying to swim
away not knowing that it can no longer breathe
underwater just like vision dies again when he
leaves the hex there were a lot of people that
were wondering if the shark might be a reference
to mephisto or nightmare or something like that
the shark itself is actually a reference to
scarlet witch because the shark is giving him the
magic to sustain the little boy so scarlet witch
is creating the magic to sustain vision so scarlet
witch is the shark think about it in a very
breaking bad situation like they're positioning
her as this really big marvel villain kevin
feige has been hyping up how they were taking her
full-blown comic book scarlet witch you will know
why she is called the scarlet witch after this
series is over meaning that they want to show
you why she's one of the most powerful people in
the mcu they even had the joke a couple episodes
ago where they were having the fanboy argument
about her killing thanos like oh she would have
clearly killed him if he wouldn't have called
down that aerial strike the composer for doctor
strange 2 was talking about how she has all this
darkness in her and they wanted her theme music
during doctor strange 2 to reflect that implying
that she's going to get even darker as a character
during this series monica rambeau some of the
other sword agents think that she's in danger but
really she is the danger but here's the thing this
is the big fake out because people are like what
if she becomes the main villain of doctor strange
2 maybe that's what they're doing on Wandavision
i think that's meant to be a fake out too because
kevin feige isn't trying to demonize mental health
issues because that's at the root of what she's
doing here in the hex and west view the hex is
kind of a response to her feeling utterly alone
and empty so she's trying to fill her life with
all the things that she always wanted for herself
or that she thought that she always wanted for
herself a totally normal family with a mundane
suburban life taking her kids to school dentist
appointments dealing with unruly house guests
neighbors but in reality she can't do any of
that because all those people are dead so what's
going on in the show right now is this this real
push-pull tug of war happening inside her own mind
between her id her ego and superego to get all
freudian like they're all fighting a massive civil
war inside her own mind for control of what she's
doing early theory as things continue to spiral
out of control this is when we'll see people like
dr strange get involved like why hasn't nick fury
stepped in to stop all this from starting like
doctor strange himself probably could have stopped
this on the first day that things got weird
probably because when this all first started
happening there was no incursion from another
dimension and that's really what doctor strange is
looking for what he's detecting with his special
systems at the sanctum he protects earth from
threats from other realities so that implies that
there is no threat from nightmare or mephisto
or any big cosmic villain when this all starts
but because we are expecting some big cosmic
villain to show up during doctor strange 2
i think that will be more towards the end of the
series and it'll have something to do with scarlet
witch's actions when things really go off the
rails when she really goes full-blown comic book
scarlet witch and that's where they create the
opportunity for other outside bigger villains to
take advantage of what's going on but hopefully
that explains what's going on with evan peters
quicksilver why it's probably just a real big mind
screw one-off thing and we're not going to see
him start appearing everywhere all over the place
inside the mcu but everyone post all your theories
in the comments below my full episode 7 video
will post on friday you can click here for that
Wandavision episode 7 trailer video and you can
click here for my full Wandavision episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!